on this episode of wheel of science
we're talking politics and space
or space force but you got to say it
differently yeah in space
there are only deep voices space
this is wheel of science
hey everybody what's up and welcome to
wheel of science i'm your host chuck
nice and this is the show
where we answer your questions about the
universe
actually i don't answer your questions
about the universe but that would be
silly
the one the only dr neil degrasse tyson
answers your questions about the
universe hey chuck
what's up neil you're doing good you
found me in my office today i think this
is the longest time that you uh
have been home yeah sometimes i got to
give the universe a rest
i i disagree with that i think the
universe can handle you
neil so neil before we get to the
questions why don't you just tell us
what
is space force yeah if that comes to
pass it would just be a sort of a
reorganization of the military
with a lot of the activities that have
already been happening
under the auspices of the air force many
people
i don't think knew the air force has a
u.s space command
within it and they're the ones that
conceived and launched the
the gps satellites um they with the nsa
and others have spy satellites in orbit
that's been going on
since the 60s spy satellites so
this concept that the military use of
space is something new no it's something
old
and all this would do would codify it
into a new branch of the armed forces so
it really already exists
it's like calling an apple pie an apple
crisp
take an apple pie and hit it with a
hammer a few times and call it apple
crisp
that's exactly what i meant
nia what time is it my friend it is time
to
spin the wheel my how formal
mike maz wants to know if and when we
colonize another planet
who has political rights over that body
welcome to the wild frontier of space
law
it's not clear the outer space treaty
stipulates that you can't own anything
in space
so the nations cannot declare it their
own
so if that holds up the answer is nobody
has jurisdiction
but i think laws
imagined many decades ago may need to be
updated and modified given what we learn
and know about the future of space
exploration
so we're in need of some enlightened
attorneys
to think this through going forward oh
god more lawyers
no better lawyers so you mentioned space
treaty what is that the outer space
treaty was a u.n document drafted in the
late 1960s
ratified by today more than 100
countries
and it's a guidelines for the peaceful
use of outer space and it's very kumbaya
you know if you're astronauts in trouble
i come help you and i bring you food and
water and
and it's it's very beautiful it's very
future
thinking but it leaves open the
possibility that you might want to
defend your assets in space
with some form of weapon or another and
see suppose you see a satellite coming
towards you and you think it's going to
hurt you
can you preemptively take it out so that
you don't get hurt
this is the fuzzy area in that document
but that doesn't subtract from the fact
that it really isn't imagine is
imagining a future
a very peaceful future of cooperation in
space which i think
in the end is a good idea look at that
gene roddenberry couldn't have done a
better job himself
yep all right neil you ready for another
one spin the wheel
jenn schifrin wants to know this don't
we already use satellites for military
action
what other ways will they militarize
space yeah when people think of the
militarization of space they're often
thinking of
star wars weapons missiles and things
problem is when you're in space and in
orbit you're going
18 000 miles an hour in low earth orbit
if you start busting stuff
up now you have particles and bits and
pieces
of formerly operating satellites that
are themselves
projectiles moving at 18 000 miles an
hour
and so you make a mess of things
so space war would last a few hours and
then you'd never have another space war
again so space has been the repository
of spy satellites
ever since we've had satellites and in
that sense it has been militarized
in fact the gulf war of 2003 was
completely enabled by space assets
with with gps satellites leading the way
which we think of as just helping you
get to grandma's house
in your car but it was conceived
launched and operated by the military
and was later co-opted
by business interests so
uh yeah it'll find grandma's house uber
their entire business model depends on
it and if you want to find a mate
within 1.5 miles of your current
location
swipe right interplanetary hookups i
like the way you think neil
you've heard me say it a million times
wix is the best
place to create your personal or
professional website i made
wheelofsigns.com on wix
i found the perfect template uploaded
our content
and hit publish it doesn't take an
astrophysicist
that's why neil didn't do it and i did
no offense neil
upgrade to a premium plan and you can
get your own website domain name
right away go to wix.com go slash star
talk
and begin are you ready for another one
spin it
j thomas asks what possible injuries or
diseases will combat doctors
in space force find themselves regularly
treating
that's a great question well that
depends on
how how much we invoke
soldiers in space as opposed to remote
controlled
satellites in space you start putting
people in space
and then they start fighting one another
you might ask well why would you do that
just put a drone
a drone satellite in space but if you
put people in space
yeah then there's the long-term effects
of zero g the
bone density loss all the same things we
currently know about
from astronauts and their long-term
visits to the international space
station
so uh that's the kind of i wouldn't call
them injuries but they're
workplace hazards i would call them
workplace conditions that are not always
in the interest of your health
or your longevity you also have exposure
to higher levels of radiation from the
sun
so you want to be protected against that
but if a missile hits you and you're
blown to bits
uh same medical needs you might have if
that happened on earth hmm
the difference is when you scream medic
in space
no one can hear you yes chuck that is
true
not only in space can no one hear you
scream
no one can hear you explode either
man bro you in dark just say it
just get real here all right it's
captured tom we took a picture of neil
and we put it up
and of course we took captions from our
viewers
and the winning caption is peter grell
i can count to two in my head but
starting at three
i gotta use my fingers that's my
favorite one too
i must agree in fact it goes a little
deeper with me because one of my
favorite most influential books growing
up
beginning in middle school was a book
called one two three
infinity written by the physicist george
gamma
and he referenced a a a a tribe
a primitive tribe where they don't have
numbers for anything bigger than three
they just can count up to three then
after that it's just very many
and so the question was how do they
think about large numbers relative to
small numbers
so i like that it's a throwback to a
time when we really didn't have to count
more than three things in our lives
i just love that while you were reading
one two three infinity i was reading one
fish two fish redfish blue fish and that
was in high school
time now for this week's poll which is
do you think we should have a space
force answer right here on this page
all right neil what do you think huh you
know if we have a space force
then the air force motto aim high
you lose the space force on that one
because they're aiming higher
so i don't know how you're going to
resolve that one but
so the air force would have to change
their model to lower your
expectations and then the then the space
force gets
the sky is not the limit which happened
to be the title of my memoir
you know what i like most about that
answer is the gangster way you slipped
in your
book plug yeah
look at that we're out of time and of
course we have to say thank you to our
very own personal astrophysicist
dr neil degrasse tyson
thank you neil thank you again neil
till next time jack
total design freedom that's what you get
when you make a website using the wix
editor
you want motion background well you got
it you want an online store
well that's wix feature animated page
transitions
you guessed it you can do it on wix yeah
i like this
let's do it you can either use
wix adi to let an artificial design
intelligence
build your site for you or you can use
their wide variety of templates to get
exactly the site that you had in mind
upgrade to a custom domain like we have
at wheelofscience.com
and let the world know about your site
so what are you waiting for
the wix.com slash go slash star talk
and begin your site now believe me if
i can do it you can do it no way i'm as
smart as you
that's our show we'll see you next time
i'm chuck nice thanks for watching
wheel of science
you